d'avoir répondu à notre convocation
dansant cette commission d'enquête sur
le narcotrafic et les moyens d'médier je
vais procéder l'obligation formelle de
prestation de serment qui prévaut devant
une commission d'enquête parlementaire
je vous rappelle qu' un faux témoignage
devant notre commission est passible des
peines prévu aux articles 434-
13-1- 15 du code pénal et je vais vous
inviter chacune d'entre vous à prêter
serement de dire toutes les rien que la
vérité à lever la main droite et à dire
je le jure je jure je jure merci
euh nous vous proposons
d'ouvrir nos échanges par un propos
liminire et puis ensuite on procédera au
jeu des questionsréponses avec notre
rapporteur Étienne blanc et les
collègues qui sont présents je vous
laisse vous
organiser euh mon ma collaboratrice
madame
meer pour vous parler un petit peu du
territoire gardois euh que vous
connaissez voilà je pense un peu et qui
a beaucoup fait parler de lui ces
derniers temps euh un territoire donc
d'abord je dois dire je ne suis pas le
seul procureur puisqu'il y a un deuxième
tribunal judiciaire à Alès mais je m
fait au suspense en vous disant que pour
avoir travaillé sous un certain nombre
de forme d'ors et déjà il est acquis que
la problématique des stupéfiants euh
d'alè renvoie euh plutôt vers les
Sévines et n'a finalement pas de lien
direct avec le ressort du tribunal
judiciaire de de nîes donc un territoire
gardois pour autant euh qui a cette
particularité de se situer à la croisée
de grands axes routiers euh qui arrive
d'un côté de l'Italie qui surtout de
l'autre côté arrive de l'Espagne qui
Bala donc ce que nous appelons
communément l'arc méditerranéen pour
remonter via le la vallée du Rhône vers
le nord de la France enfin le centre
puis le Nord euh un lieu de passage qui
évidemment euh est à la fois à l'origine
de procédures
euh qui consiste à à interpeller des
personnes qui ne sont pas d'ici qui ne
sont pas de de du gare et qui ne sont
que des convoyeurs d'un point A à un
point B le cas échéant d'ailleurs
étranger provenant de l'étranger pour un
pays étranger mais également un point de
passage important où s'arrête euh des
livraisons de stupéfiants qui vont
repartir pour parti ailleurs et qui vont
aussi alimenter localement le trafic
donc c'est une situation géographique
euh assez assez spécifique en cela et
qui de par ce point d'entrée sortie euh
va générer un certain nombre de
difficultés sur l'identification des
réseaux c'est une grande variété donc de
délinquences diff différente et de
criminalité différente euh je dirais
aussi que nî est un tribunal judiciaire
qui y est à à peu près à éidistance de
deux pôles un pôle à gauche qui est
celui de de Montpellier dont la
délinquence est là encore différente
mais qui attire un certain nombre
d'effectifs à commencé par
l'implantation de ce qui était notre
antenne police judiciaire et de l'autre
côté évidemment le pôle marseillais avec
sa délinquence mais également sa
juridiction interrégionale spécial
et euh la particularité est à ce point
complexe que nous faisons donc le grand
écart entre d'une part des unités de
police qui peuvent relever de l'héros et
de l'autre des unités qui vont venir sur
des petits territoires qui constituent
presque des enclaves en réalité qui vont
nous inviter à essayer de travailler
mais bien sûr plus difficilement avec
les sûretés départementales et la police
judiciaire des bouches du rhô et puis
même chose dans le département 84
puisque nous avons cette ville de
Villeneuve les Avignons qui n'est pas
sans incidence qui est toute petite mais
qui se situe sur un bassin de de
délinquence en matière de stupéfiant qui
n'est pas non plus complètement
transparente ce qui veut dire que tout
ça conduit quand même à devoir jongler
avec un certain nombre d'acteurs et à
devoir les amener à se rencontrer et je
j'y reviendrai dans dans un second temps
quelles sont les solutions mises en
œuvre pour essayer de lutter contre ces
trafics là aussi je vous coupe
directement le département en deux pour
vous dire que finalement nous avons un
bassin et on parle de bassin de
criminalité finalement et non pas de
territoire judiciaire et c'est bien tout
l'enjeu de passer ces frontières là nous
avons un bassin au sud qui est celui de
nîes et le sud du ressort et qui va
s'étendre vers Marseille après être
passé par le territoire 84 de Arles et
là aussi peut-être en reparlerons-nous
puisque si je fais l'évolution dans le
sens inverse la délinquence marseillaise
qui arrive aujourd'hui sur nî a commencé
par s'embarrer d'Arles et puis plus au
nord le ressort dit de bagnoolle sur 16
qui est la ville principale et qui va
renvoyer sur un un réseau là ancré avec
les villes de l'autre côté du Rhône nous
travaillons avec les unités les parquets
de Carpentra et
d'Avignon donc deux points principaux où
s'exerce ce narcotrafic avec toutes les
incidences qui peuvent en résul nous y
reviendrons un ressort dont vous le
savez probablement qui est très
papérisé 4e département de France le
plus pauvre avec une population dite
dans les quartiers en nombre très très
important et des concentrations qui
évidemment favorisent ces trafics vous
avez probablement tous en tête l'image
notamment de ce quartier que tout le
monde connaît aujourd'hui qui s'appelle
Pissevin sur lequel nous travaillons
énormément mais qui reste une ville en
soi une petite particularité
géographique aussi pas inintéressante
des quartiers qui sont excentrés du
centreville qui l'entoure alors c'est
pas en soit un scoop hein ça existe dans
d'autres endroits mais ça peut être une
question quand on s'interroge sur des
solutions plus politique de la ville sur
comment sortir ces quartiers d'un
certain isolement et d'un mode de
fonctionnement en économie circulaire
voilà des quartier aussi et un ressort
aussi le gare qui est un point de
vigilance quand il s'agit euh de lutter
de d'être prudent et et prévenir sur les
problématiques de radicalisation
violente et c'est pas sans incidence non
plus puisqu'on sait très bien que tout
le Terrero du Terrero si je puis dire
pardon euh c'est euh soutendu par des
nécessités financière et ce financement
il faut qu'il arrive de quelque part et
là encore je pense que nous y
reviendrons si on parle finance on parle
d'une are de la guerre euh ce territoire
et bien c'est un territoire qui
évidemment a été marqué de façon très
récente par les évolutions en matière de
criminalité l'histoire du Petit Fayed
évidemment qui a fait plus qu'émouvoir
tout le monde qui a littéralement secoué
et bouleversé y compris enfin au premier
chef localement t tous les acteurs qui a
peut-être aussi permis de revoir un
certain une certaine façon de de
travailler voilà je je propose de passer
tout de suite la parole euh à ma ma
collaboratrice madame meer substitut
pour une définition un peu plus précise
de ce trafic à proprement parler oui
merci alors effectivement pour ce qui
concerne nî nous on ne travaille pas que
sur nî on a d'autres pôles qui nous
occupent beaucoup notamment bagnoolle
sur 16 et puis d'autres zones mais plus
particulièrement sur nî pour vous faire
un peu une idée à nî on a quatre
quartiers principaux on a la ZUP qui
concerne la zupe Sud pisevin la zupe
Nord valde Gour qui héberge 14400
personnes
on estime en tout cas c'est des données
policières on estime à 30000 30000 € de
chiffre d'affaires par jour par jour en
matière de vente de stupéfiants on a
également toujours anime le quartier du
mass de Mingue 3000 habitants chiffre
d'affaires en matière de vente de
stupéfiant 15000 € par jour et puis
ensuite le chemin bas d'Avignon 7100
habitants 10000 € de chiffre d'affaires
par jour donc on est effectivement sur
des sommes qui sont brassées de par ces
activités illicites qui sont extrêmement
importantes en ce qui concerne la
délinquence dans ces quartiers-là la
délinquence qui vous intéresse le
narcobanditisme des stupéfiants bien
évidemment cannabis cocaïne on a assez
peu sur notre ressort de l'héroïne je
sais qu'en France dans d'autres zones un
peu plus pauvres il y a de l'héroïne sur
le ressort deuny on en a assez peu je
vous diraiis pas qu'on en a pas mais on
en a peu euh et puis tout ce qui est
est-ce que vous appelez ces infractions
connexes les infractions qui gravitent
autour de la vente de stupéfiant euh
principalement euh les tentatives de
meurtre les meurtres les assassinats les
meurtres en bande organisé sur l'année
2023 on a eu six morts six morts en lien
avec directement en lien avec le trafic
de stupéfiant et ce que j'appelle des
tentatives de meurtre sérieus quand je
vous dis sérieuse c'est parce qu'on a eu
des personnes qui ont été blessé par
balle de manière importante grièvement
blessé avec parfois des pronostics vital
engagés donc 14 sur l'année 2023 euh la
délinquence la criminalité elle évolue
elle connaît des évolution qu'on
constate ces derniers temps avec une
accélération alors parfois par pic
c'est-à-dire par vague avec une
accélération une période d'acalmie une
réaccélération et quand je vous parle
d'accélération je prends cet exemple de
l'été 2023 avec en 5 jours en 5 jours
même je vous dirais presque 4 jours et
demi 4 jours et demi on a eu quatre
épisodes importants
de de de tentative d'assassinat voire
d'assassinat premier épisode on est à la
zupnord donc quartier de cours des tirs
d'intimidation avec usage d'armes de
guerre avec personne qui n'a été blessé
fort heureusement mais on a eu quand
même deux interpellations le lendemain
toujours dans le même quartier on a deux
mineurs de nationalité espagnolle qui se
trouvent toujours sur ce point de Deal
l'un va être gravement blessé au tel
point à tel point que son pronostic
vital va être engagé pendant plusieurs
jours et puis ça ne s'arrête pas là le
jour d'après cette fois-ci à laazup Sud
donc quartier rival ou en tout cas
quartier opposé on a effectivement cette
cette cet assassinat du jeune du jeune
Fayed euh au sein de de de ce quartier
là et le surlendemain donc là on se
demande mais quand est-ce que ça va
s'arrêter le sur lendemain et bien on a
le un un jeune qui également se trouve à
la ZUP sud sur le point de Deal le point
de vente de stupéfiant qui lui arrive de
baéisier et qui va également être
assassiné assassiné donc on a quatre
épisodes très graves très graves avec
des blessés des blessés graves avec mort
d'homme mort d'enfant sur une période
qui est très très
rapprochée on constate aussi un
déplacement de cette criminalité qu'on
rencontre souvent en zone urbaine le
plus souvent en zone urbaine on constate
que cette criminalité elle se déplace
aussi dans des zones qui sont dites plus
rurales et je vous donne un exemple un
dossier qui date il y a quelques mois
déjà mais qui révèle vraiment ça à
savoir qu'on a une des des personnes qui
sont connues comme étant membres de la
ZUP Sud donc le quartier pisevin à nî
qui se sont mis au vert qui se sont mis
à l'écart de la de la ville de nîes qui
se sont trouvés un petit terrain avec un
abri de fortune à 30 minutes de NIM donc
en zone gendarmerie dans une zone qui
est quand même rurale et qui vont être
attaqués par une bande adverse par des
autres individus attaqué à l'arme de
guerre avec des dizaines et des dizaines
de tirs en rafale avec des kalashnikov
on sait qu'il y a au moins quatre armes
kalashnikov diff différentes qui ont été
utilisé ce jour-là et donc on constate
effectivement ce déplacement de la
criminalité euh de la zone urbaine vers
la zone la zone rurale et on constate
également une évolution en ce qui
concerne le profil les profils des
personnes qui sont impliqué dans le
trafic mais aussi des personnes qui sont
impliquées dans ces infractions connexes
et dans les règlements de compte dans
les usages des armes euh on a des
personnes qui sont de plus en plus
jeunes des personnes qui sont même
parfois mineures euh qui sont euh peu
expérimenter euh peu expérimenter ça
veut dire aussi euh qu's sont peu formés
formés qui manie les armes comme on a pu
leur apprendre dans les jours qui
précèdent euh avec des risques alors le
risque bien évidemment il recherche la
la mort de personne mais des risques à
savoir euh des des erreurs sur la
personne des victimes collatérales on en
a on a des dossiers où effectivement on
constate ces éléments-là et puis euh
autre élément sur ces personnes qui sont
peu expérimentées c'est des personnes
qui euh n'ont pas forcément des des
antécédents judiciaires ou pas forcément
des antécédents judiciaires importantes
importants euh de telle sorte que déjà
on se demande comment ils se retrouent
directement impliqués dans des faits
aussi graves et puis aussi des personnes
qui de fait sont plus difficilement
repérables parce que des personnes qui
sont ancrées dans la délinquence on les
connaît les services de police les
connaissent on les surveill c'est un
bien grand mot mais en tout cas on les a
dans le collimateur ça c'est des
personnes qui sont euh finalement
quasiment inconnu et qu'on identifie peu
on con St aussi euh on a de plus en plus
d'individus qui viennent de l'extérieur
c'est-à-dire que euh traditionnellement
c'est la personne qui a grandi dans le
quartier qui connaît son quartier qui va
trafiquer dans le quartier et qui va
défendre son quartier
euh on constate euh je vous parlais tout
à l'heure de ce jeune homme qui a été
assassiné qui venait de bzier de ces
deux jeunes deux jeunes qui se
trouvaient sur le point de d'Al qui
étaient espagnol on constate aussi de
plus en plus d'individus qui arrivent
des bouches de rô et qui arrivent plus
particulièrement de Marseille voilà euh
avec à la fois pour le trafic de
stupéfiants mais également pour les
opérations armées avec des binôme qui se
constituent avec une personne qui est
locale qui connaît son quartier et qui
s'associe à une personne extérieure
personne extérieure qui sont recrutés
sur les réseaux sociaux qui arrivent de
Marseille on le sait notamment dans des
dossiers où on a des des individus qui
ont revendiqué en venant en venant s'en
prendre àim qui ont revendiqué ici c'est
Marseille et enfin
euh on a des alliances qui sont qui sont
faites des alliances entre certains
quartiers qui s'associent parce qu'ils
ont le même ils ont le même le même
ennemi et on a aussi des alliances qu'on
attend pas c'est-à-dire que couramment
on sait quel quartier s'associe à quel
quartier et ça évolue donc il y a aussi
des choses qu'on essaie de comprendre
mais c'est pas toujours aussi clair que
que ça pourrait le laisser penser
peut-être sur les la continuité sur les
impacts dans les dans les quartiers
rapidement effectivement donc les les
impacts bah ce sont ceux que qui qui qui
font énormément parler d'eux
c'est-à-dire un sentiment d'insécurité
très important des gens qui sont plus en
sécurité même chez eux quand des balles
peuvent traverser un mur et tuer une
personne c'est un risque de repli des
institutions des services publics c'est
la fermeture d'une médiathèque àim euh
qui euh voilà qui est suivi
rapidement de de du retrait des
transports publics c'est la sécurisation
d'écoes qui insécurise ceux qui sont
sécurisés bon voilà c'est c'est un
phénomène que tout le monde connaît
contre lequel évidemment il convient de
lutter au plus vite c'est aussi une
économie circulaire c'est-à-dire qu'en
réalité des quartiers qui vivent en
autonomie euh et dans lesqueles il faut
arriver à intervenir pour aller chercher
euh enfin scinder ce qui va bien de ce
qui ne va pas bien dans les activités
qu'elle soi médicale qu'elle soit
commerciale et cetera et cetera pour
arriver à redonner une une vie sociale
normale à à ses habitants euh évidemment
l'incidence de du retrait d'un transport
public elle est elle est monstrueuse
surtout que je vous le disais au début
ce sont des quartiers qui sont un petit
peu à l'écart du centre-ville donc voilà
tout ça enchaîne fait que c'est des
repliis de quartier qui finit par donner
encore plus de puissance à ceux qui
tentent de prendre tendre la main sur
ces quartiers là évidemment on pourra
reparler d'urbanisation même si on n'est
pas au premier chef sur ces sur ces ces
problématique mais des incidences très
importantes quand il s'agit de constater
qu'il y a des endroits où l'intervention
des des nouvelles technologie d'enquête
des techniques spéciales d'enquête sont
quasiment impossibles parce que la
configuration est telle qu'on est
empêché et qu'à un moment donné c'est la
réalité du terrain qui qui empêche un
petit peu d'avancer voilà
donc le le le voilà sur l'impact
l'impact évidemment plus plus
directement lié à nos fonctions c'est
l'impact
judiciaire c'est-à-dire que face à un
déploiement de violence il y a un
déploiement de réaction de la part des
forces de l'ordre il y a des arrivées
massives de par exemple de de de forces
sécurité intérieur en matière de
sécurisation mais qui vont de fait avoir
un impact positif on le voit ça finit
par apaiser la situation ça rassure les
habitants mais ça génère euh de
l'activité judiciaire j'allais dire
l'activité du quotidien à laquelle il
faut quand même répondre et plus que
jamais de façon ferme parce qu'on voit
bien que nous avons des enjeux et
parallèlement évidemment ça renvoie à
toute la problématique de la suffisance
en nombre en
compétences des services d'enquête qui
ont vocation à enquêter sur les faits
euh qui a être saisi qui a ne pas l'être
et surtout qui a se coordonner lorsque
sur cinq affaires dont on vient de vous
expliquer qu'elles s'enchaînent d'un
jour sur l'autre au final il y en a deux
qui vont partir en GIR et les trois
autres vont rester au parquet de nîes à
un moment donné ça ordonne de repenser
les méthodes de travail alors on se
tourne vers les collègues de la geirs et
on propose de
mutualiser ces réunions de travail très
opérationnel que nous avons commencé à
mettre en place à nî quand je dis
opérationnel c'est du travail de quasi
enquêteur hein le de la République
dirige l'action publique mais mais à un
moment donné il se transforme quasiment
en super enquêteur qui va essayer de
faire se recouper des informations dont
on s'aperçoit parfois que les services
les services police gendarmerie ne les
ont pas identifi comme étant les
informations des uns des autres et c'est
là que le travail prend tout son sens
mais prend tout son temps aussi c'est un
travail très intéressant très
chronophage qui permet de faire venir et
et et j'allais dire merci au cè cèg de
laagir d'avoir joué le jeu ils se sont
spécialisés territorialement au niveau
de Marseille ils ont des référents ni
moi qui d'ailleurs ont en partie déjà
travaillé sur nî donc la JIRS de
Marseille accepte de venir travailler
dans ses comités opérationnels de lutte
contre la crimorgue nimoise et on
échange et là encore merci de cette
aussi participation aux collègues
magistrat du siège juge d'instruction
qui accepte de rentrer dans ces
instances où l'on échange de
l'information qui découvre aussi des
informations importantes dans le cadre
de leurs de leurs instructions et et et
là on essaie de tout recouper c'est un
travail colossal qui à un moment donné
va trouver ses limites les limites elles
sont essentiellement au nombre de deux
elles sont matérielles et pratiques à un
moment donné quand on a x enquêteurs
judiciaire en matière de police
judiciaire ben on n a pas x + 2 x + 3
alors si temporairement on a un renfort
mis à disposition par le ministre de
l'Intérieur de 10opj rapidement pour
trava travailler sur les deux affaires
mais qui d'ailleurs sont les affaires
qui sont parties à la geirs on a cette
chance de voir arriver le le le GIR 30
un GIR départemental qui est en train de
s'installer qui va monter en puissance
jusqu'à monter à 10 en avril prochain
mais enfin globalement la réalité c'est
de dire quand on a tout le monde qui est
mobilisé sur deux affaires à 100 % c'est
dur de faire travailler tout de suite
sur les trois autres affaires donc ça ce
sont des réalités très pratiques très
matérielles il va falloir prioriser
constamment alors je suis pas sûr qu'on
ait vraiment le temps parce que dès
qu'on déstabilise un peu un réseau on a
même pas le temps de de d'être proactif
que l'autre s'installe qu'il faudrait
avoir une autre équipe prête à attaquer
ce deuxème réseau voilà l'autre réalité
ça va être parfois des limites qui sont
tout à fait juridiques jusqu'où on peut
échanger quel type d'information où
pouvons-nous créer ces instances qui
vont nous permettre d'avoir des échanges
pour avoir du renseignement j'allais
dire du renseignement de territoire on
va pas dire territorial du renseignement
de territoire comme on peut le faire par
exemple en matière de radicalisation
violente euh comment va-t-on pouvoir
croiser des fichiers comment aujourd'hui
al lorsqu'on sait que tout un tas de
professions par judiciaire travail avec
l'intelligence artificielle pour croiser
des données chercher des nullités dans
les procédures sans avoir à les lire
comment est-ce que nous enquêteur
justice allons-nous pouvoir utiliser
cette intelligence artificielle mais pas
que pour monde dossier ou par que pour
mes deux dossiers pour que tous les
dossiers qui nous lient les uns aux
autres et qui nous obligent à travailler
ensemble soient moulinés par cette
intelligence artificielle et nous
sortent voilà des alertes des
recoupements qui vont nous permettre pas
seulement d'avoir une idée sur le fait
que X ou Y est la cible que nous
cherchons à atteindre mais qui vont nous
donner les éléments sur le fait que nous
allons sortir des preuve objectives dans
notre système de droit rappelons quand
même que le procureur est là pour
prouver et qui vont nous permettre
d'avancer sur ces investigations je
crois qu'on est dans une course non pas
à l'information mais au traitement de
l'information aujourd'hui qui s'avère
indispensable évidemment derrière tout
ça j'allais dire devant tout ça il y a
pas une réunion qui peut commencer sans
que moi je rappelle en tout cas cherchez
l'argent vous trouverez les stupéfiant
autant dire qu'on change de paradigme il
faut aller chercher les avoirs il faut
aller chercher ce que le trafic de
stupéfiant rapporte pour essayer de
toucher au plus haut et et je m'arrête
là sur la présentation nimoise
merci beaucoup Mame le procureur je vous
propose d'enchaîner ça vous convient oui
très bien merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur mes messieurs les
sénateurs alors moi je vais vous dresser
la même façon une description du ressort
qui est le mien donc qu ressort de
dunkererc ce sera un petit peu différent
parce que c'est une taille de tribunal
qui est différente et les problématiques
mais je pense que c'est le sujet de
cette table ronde de les faire se
confronter nous ne sommes pas exposés au
même aux mêmes difficultés ce qui nous
intéresse d'ailleurs
c'est qu'on puisse tirer des des des
mécaniques des choses qui se répliquent
enfin ce qui vous différencie bien sûr
mais aussi ce qui peut être mur s en
chapeau bien sûr eu donc pour vous dire
moi j'ai pris mon poste donc en le le
1er septembre dernier donc c'est encore
un ressort que je que je découvre eu
pour vous dire tout de suite de quelle
taille je parle nous au sein du parquet
on est 7 moi comprisi j'ai une personne
qui s'occupe des trafics de stupéfiant
mais qui ne fait pas que ça et en terme
de force de l'ordre pense que pour que
ces auditions soient utiles il faut que
les capteurs de terrain soient les plus
je pense les plus authentiques
clairement nous nos enquêtes que nous
diligentons sur les trafics de
stupéfiants au sein du parquet de duncer
qu'elles sont principalement diligentées
au stade on va dire local en tout cas au
stade du du du commissariat ce qu'on
appelle la sûreté urbaine il y a un
groupe spécialisé pour les stupéfiants
mais je pense que c'est intéressant
parce que vous vous aurez aussi la
description de de ma collègue qui est à
Lille nous partageons le même
département et il y a des services qui
sont plutôt départementaux qui sont
plutôt mobilisés sur la métropole
lilloise donc pour vous dire voilà pour
ce qui est de de l'état des forces c'est
assez modeste mais euh néanmoins il y a
beaucoup de choses qui sont mises en
place et je vais vous les détailler je
pense que euh ce que je peux vous dire
sur la le ressort juste à très grand
près pour que vous en compreniez les
enjeux c'est que je pense que vous avez
la carte en tête la particularité de
notre ressort c'est que nous avons euh à
l'Est notre frontière de ressort c'est
tout simplement la frontière belge euh
euh au nord c'est la façade maritime
avec le port et juste en dessous de ce
territoire un peu proche de de de de la
mer nous avons un un grand autoroute qui
traverse de part en part notre sort et
qui du coup amène beaucoup beaucoup de
flux euh entre la Belgique et et et la
France et nous avons quasiment pour
faire un schéma de façon perpendiculaire
un autre autoroute qui nous relie à lîle
et qui est lui aussi une un grande un
grand trajet de de stupéf
sont des autes P euh non sur non non
c'est pas c'est pas entre non justement
c'est que non voilà c'est pour ça que ça
va très vite non non c'est pour ça que
ça va c'est pour ça que ça va ça va très
vite euh donc il y a cette cette
circulation là qui est facilité je vous
donne un élément très enraciné dans le
territoire mais qui a son importance en
terme de de flux justement de mouvement
on a une particularité sur la la
l'agglomération d'unkererque c'est que
tous les bus sont gratuits donc ça
facilite aussi les trajets des clients
qui peuvent se rendre plus facilement
sur les sur les points d'il euh donc on
a ça on a donc comme vous voulez décrire
avec la frontière un enjeu international
cette proximité de la Belgique mais
aussi euh à voile d'oiseau quasiment
Amsterdam les Pays-Bas qui sont tout
proches enverse que l'on peut rejoindre
en moins de 2 heures en voiture donc on
a vraiment un territoire qui est euh
voilà enserré dans toute dans tous ces
aspectsl euh la table ronde que vous
nous proposez elle se focalise sur la
zone Z urbaine donc je vais à dessin
donner plus de relief à mon propos sur
nous les les plus grandes zones urbaines
de notreessort et ce don sont donc ces
ces villes de dunkererque de de grandes
Saintes notamment qui sont sur cette
façade maritime que j'ai expliqué donc
entre la mer et et
l'autoroute donc ça c'est pour un petit
peu vous dresser un un un portrait très
rapide de ce que nous avons dans notre
ressort du point de vue de l'activité
juridictionnelle jeis évidemment pas
vous assommer de chiffres je pense que
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que par
rapport à ce qui vous a été décrit euh
très concrètement encore une fois pour
vous dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont la réalité euh de de des
infractions de stupéfiants qui sont
géréses par le parquet de d'unkererc en
nombre en tout cas sont aujourd'hui euh
beaucoup euh des faits de d'usage nous
avons d'autres procédures évidemment euh
de de de pour démanteler les trafics
mais ce sont pas les plus nombreuses
sont celles qui nous demandent le plus
de temps pour les raisons qui ont été
exposées juste avant moi mais en terme
quantitatif et sans rentrer dans les
chiffres je pense que c'est ce qu'il
faut euh euh euh retenir nous envoyons
dès que nous le pouvons dès que nous
pouvons creuser euh des euh des dossiers
à l'information judiciaire c'estàdire
que nous saisissons un magistrat
instructeur mais à grand trait encore
une fois la majorité des procédures que
nous essayons de mener nous essayons de
les mener euh directement au devant le
tribunal correctionnel pour que si
justement des réponses euh rapides euh
voilà pour ce qui est de de de
l'activité juridictionnelle s'agissant
de la description du trafic moi ce que
je peux vous dire aujourd'hui sur ce qui
se passe dans notre ressort c'est que
euh la tendance est évidemment à la
hausse mais ça je pense que euh je suis
à l'unisson de de l'ensemble de mes
collègues s'agissant des produits
puisque c'était une de vos questions le
cannabis reste la la la matière
stupéfiante qui est la plus achetée et
et et et consommée bien sûr on a un peu
une stabilisation du du du prix euh je
rebondis sur ce qu'a dit ma collègue
tout à l'heure sur notre sort il y a une
une recrue d'essence de l'héroïne avec
une baisse du du du prix de l'héroïne
qui est assez significative et qui je
pense mérite d'être sous souligner la
cocaïne chez nous bien sûr ça existe
mais c'est pas le plus important de ce
qui est vendu parce que les les tarifs
restent quand même assez hauts et que ça
s'adapte pas forcément aux populations
que nous avons alors elle elle encore
une fois elle existe elle reste consommé
dans des cercles qui sont fermés mais
c'est néanmoins pas le le le le le plus
le plus
important comme phénomène un petit peu
significatif qui me semble utile
d'épingler moi je je avec mes collègues
à qui j'ai j'ai préparé cette audition
nous souhaitions vous porter à votre
connaissance le fait que on a euh de
plus en plus alors encore une fois ça ça
ça commence donc c'est pas
quantitativement très important mais ça
mérite d'être signalé euh des des
dossiers où on voit de la cocaïne qui
est coupée euh on prend euh de la
substance pure au départ on la coupe on
en fait du crack euh et ça ça apparaît
quand même un peu plus fréquemment
qu'auparavant euh et également un autre
élément euh qui n'a pas pris une ampleur
statistique euh très importante mais qui
mérite d'être signalé nous avons
quelques exemples euh de Dossi avec des
drogues de synthèse du type speed avec
des substances qui sont à ce point
fortes que nous avons dû encore une fois
très concrètement pour vous illustrer
les choses euh parfois procédait des
interpellations plutôt que ce que nous
envisageions parce qu'il y avait un
enjeu presque d'ordre public quasiment
sanitaire euh voilà s'agissant des
profils des trafiquants cela vous
intéressait je pense qu'on est sur des
des architectures assez classiques comme
celles qui vous ont été je pense assez
fréquemment décrites ce que l'on peut
signaler nous concernant c'est que pour
ce qui est du stockage ce que l'on ce
que l'on dit être les nourris je pense
que ce sont une terminologie que vous
finissiez par par acquérir ce qu'on
relève nous c'est que les on a de plus
en plus de résidents dans des logements
sociaux qui sont à qui l'on demande un
petit peu comme ce qui ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure des gens qui n'ont
absolument aucun casier judiciaire qui
sont absolument pas connus mais dont on
va justement euh
souhaiter se mettre à l'abri de leur
réputation ou du fait qu'ils ne sont pas
connus pour leur demander de stocker les
stupéfiants au plus près des point deal
euh autre élément intéressant le fait
que les vendeurs on a de plus en plus de
mineurs qui sont utilisés d'abord parce
qu'évidemment comme vous le savez les
responsabilités pénales ne sont pas les
mêmes et aussi parce que un mineur va
plus faire ce qu'on lui dit en terme
d'amplitude horaire est un peu corvéable
à merci donc c'est aussi quelque chose
qui qui est assez symptomatique euh
s'agissant euh des pratiques des
trafiquants je pense que ce qui est
important de noter parce que comme on a
le port on pourrait penser que
l'approvisionnement se fait directement
par les containers en fait en réalité
encore une fois le le le le quotidien de
nos trafic de stupéfiant c'est davantage
des trafiquants qui viennent
s'approvisionner directement en fait à
l'île et c'est pour ça que j'inister en
introduction sur l'autoroute ou même qui
vont chercher dans des quantités
importantes leur mat tire stupéfiante
dans au Pays-Bas ou ou en Belgique ce
sont ces modalitéslà d'approvisionnement
qui sont privilégiées eu s'agissant de
la topographie un petit peu des des
trafics euh il y a pas beaucoup de
points de vente en fait il y en a on
peut-être moins d'une dizaines ils sont
assez assez
identifiés c'est évidemment difficile
d'apprécier les choses de façon précise
mais ce que l'on comprend c'est que le
bénéfice de la vente par jour par
vendeur est à peu près de de 3 à 4000 €
donc ça suggère quand il y a des points
de deal avec près d'une dizaine de
vendeurs ça vous donne tout de même une
une idée de de de
l'importance ce que je constate aussi
avec mes collègues et et et et les
enquêteurs c'est que nous avons affaire
à des pratique commercial comme du
commerce licite je pense que ça aussi ça
vous a été dit dans d'autres ressorts
c'est le cas d' autre avec une notion de
service quoi tout simplement donc on se
met au plus proche de la la clientèle
euh on fait des livraisons à à domicile
nos enquêteurs utilisent même la notion
de d'ubérisation on a une pratique
tarifaire attractif on fait des
promotions des enfin c'est pas des
cartes de fidélité mais quasiment
lorsque vous êtes client régulier vous
avez des des prix euh quand on parraine
également on a des prix on a des
relances à la consommation euh on
entretient le contact on fait du
démarchage agressif et cetera et tout ça
bien sûr s doosse à l'utilisation des
réseaux sociaux euh en l'occurrence chez
nous principalement snapchat euh donc
voilà pour la la configuration de notre
réseau s'agissant des infractions
connexes et j'ai écouté avec grand
intérêt ce qui était décrit pour nîe
nous avons bien sûr nous aussi euh des
faits de violence je qualifie je dirais
néanmoins d'emblé qui sont évidemment de
bien moins grande ampleur et surtout ce
qui me semble avoir un intérêt à vous
signaler c'est que nous ne sommes pour
l'instant pas tant que ça confronté à
des conflits entre les familles ou entre
les réseaux euh lorsqu'il y a des faits
de violence et d' avavantage au sein
d'une filière parce qu'il y a des pertes
de produits euh parce qu'il y a de de de
volontairement du vol on a évidemment
quelques règlements de compte mais
jamais de de en tout cas pas jamais mais
pas si fréquemment que ça avec une telle
gravité que ce qui a été décrit pour
pour nî eu donc c'est voilà je pense que
c'est assez important que que que vous
le que vous le sachiez euh on essaie au
maximum avec les enquêteurs ils
appellent ça même des des des opérations
de harcèlement de points d'il donc
d'être là de façon répétée mais il se
trouve que les points d'il sont en fait
tenus de façon assez claire par des
famille et c'est assez identifié et pour
l'instant c'est assez respecté
euh pour terminer sur vous nous
interroger sur le les liens avec les
autres acteurs donc c'est c'est bien que
je prenne la parole avant mes collègues
de de Lille parce que évidemment notre
principal euh acteur judiciaire sur ce
sujet c'est c'est la geirs vous nous
interrogez sur nos compes contact je
crois que la relation elle est alors
nouvelle pour moi depuis septembre mais
très étroite et le contact est très
fluide nous avons encore là au mois de
janvier une procédure de saisie de
stupéfiant chez nous qui a qui a ensuite
été reprise par la Gears je pense que
c'est indispensable on est
complémentaire je pense qu'il faut être
conscient de ses forces et ses capacités
il y a des choses que les GIR peuvent
faire que nous ne pouvons pas faire au
niveau local donc moi ce que j'estime
être mon rôle c'est d'être la meilleure
vigie possible passer les informations
dès que possible nous avons des projets
ensemble notamment avec le port pour
voir ce que l'on peut faire les unes
avec les autres mais je crois que c'est
voilà en tout cas à l'échelle de notre
sort il y a il y a vraiment une très
grande fluidité une très grande
coopération l'administration
pénitentiaire vous les évoquiez comme
autres acteur oui en effet pour nous
c'est une vigilance et avec ce détail
particulier que la maison d'arrêtte
d'unkererque a encore des cellules
collectives donc ça pose des des vous le
devinez c'est un Terrero assez favorable
à au trafic de stupéfiant depuis depuis
la la détention
euh s'agissant des des élus bien sûr
nous les associons euh nous essayons de
faire des choses de avec des schémas qui
sont adaptés donc j'ai notamment en tête
récemment une réunion qu'on a pu
organiser avec la sous-préfecture le
maire de grande sainte les bailleurs
sociaux pour parler concrètement de tel
immeuble de telle dame qui habite à tel
étage et de ce qui a pu être dit ou ou
répété on essaie voilà d'être au plus
proche de ce qui existe sur le sur le
terrain et puis s'agissant enfin de la
coopération B évidemment nous nous nous
utilisons tous les leviers possibles
notamment celui de la décision d'enquête
européenne ça fonctionne évidemment très
bien avec avec la Belgique et et les
Pays-Bas la coopération est globalement
satisfaisante donc voilà donc s'agissant
des des des perspectives pour terminer
euh moi je suis assez consciente que
voilà nous allons faire peut-être encore
davantage de choses avec avec le le le
le port et et c'est voilà pour essayer
de de monter des enquêtes d'envergure
pour essayer de remonter parce que pour
moi c'est le minimum quand on a un délit
flagrant qui est fait de l'emmener dev
le tribunal ça c'est le le minimum que
l'on peut faire à l'échelle d'un parquet
le but est évidemment de remonter
d'essayer de creuser donc ça on va
encore renforcer les choses moi ce à
quoi je suis très attentif c'est que
vous le savez d'unkererque c'est aussi
un foyer de
réindustrialisation colossal qui est
annoncé avec plusieurs milliers
d'emplois industriels qu'on nous promet
depuis enfin d'ici 2030 ce qui veut dire
beaucoup de nouveaux habitants beaucoup
de travailleurs et donc évidemment une
consommation de stupéfiants qui va euh
et de vente du coup qui va qui va
s'accroître donc là-dessus nous
resterons bien sûr particulièrement
vigilants et puis sur vous interrogz sur
l'évolution des moyens évidemment nous
essayons de faire ce que nous pouvons
sur l'enjeu de la saisie des stupéfiants
eu j'insistais sur les réseaux sociaux
tout à l'heure ben juste pour vous dire
qu'on attend avec impatience la
déclinaison au niveau local de la la
directive et du réglement sur l'accès à
la preuve électronique dans les enquêtes
pénales parce qu'on en aura quand même
très très largement besoin même si à mon
avis la question du chiffrement restera
importante et sur sur la réforme de la
police je fais quoi ce que je disais
tout à l'heure nous nous nous attendons
aussi de voir parce qu'il serait assez
utile que l'on puisse à la faveur de
cette réforme de la police peut-être
utiliser davantage des outils d'enquête
qui pour l'instant ne peuvent l'être
qu'au niveau départemental avec la
géolocalisation les sonorisation qui
nous impose nous à chaque fois de
requérir des services qui se trouvent à
lî et on espère que du coup il va y
avoir une mutualisation des moyens qui
nous permettront de de faire davantage à
notre à notre à notre échelle voilà
merci merci
beaucoup je vais juste reprocéder à la
prestation de serment êtesetard et de
faux témoignage devantre commission
d'enquête passible des pees priv
articles 434-3 14 et 15 du code pénal et
donc je vous inviter à prêter serment
l'une et l'autre de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité à la main droite et à
dire je le jure cette formalit accom je
vous passe la parole merci monsur
présidentie rappururs les
surz-mo je vous pr de bien vouloir
excuser notre retard mais nous avons dû
affronter les dures conditions
météorologiques du
Nord peut-être avant de commencer une
courte présentation à de voix puisque
nous avons nous allons vous faire
peut-être un point sur l'état de la
menace du narcotrafic dans le ressort
lillois mais aussi plus largement dans
le ressort de la girirs qui est bien sûr
plus important tribunal de lî est l'un
des six tribunaux judiciaires du
département du Nord lîle qui est
largement prédominant et couvre la
moitié de la population du département
soit près d'1300000 habitants et
l'agglomération lilloise représente plus
de 65 % de la délinquance
départementale c'est un ressort qui
comprend 126 communes dont 85 sur la
seule agglomération lilloise qu quatre
communes très importantes comme l'île
Roub et tourcoin et ville neuve d'Asque
et à ce titre le tribunal judiciaire de
lîle centre il faut bien le dire
l'essentiel de l'activité policière du
département c'est une population jeune
on a 30 % de la population qui a moins
de 20 ans et euh une un ressort où la
densité de la population y est
particulièrement forte ça je pense son
incidence c'est aussi un ressort avec
des contrastes très importants entre des
villes très aisées et puis des villes
très pauvres on a quand même 45 % de la
population de la ville de roubet qui vit
sous le seuil de prov de pauvreté une
coexistence de certaines grandes
réussites industrielles et puis un taux
de chômage qui reste quand même
supérieur à la moyenne nationale alors
un ressort qui se caractérise par la
présence de nombreux trafics de
stupéfiants c'est important parce que je
vous parlerai de de nécessaire
infographie cartographie d'information
dont nous manquons encore le ministère
de l'Intérieur évoquait 251 points de
deal en 2020 sur 3952 points de Deal du
territoire national et en 2022 euh nous
parlions de 170 points de vente recensés
dans le Nord dont une grande partie dans
le la métropole lilloise alors je pense
que pour dakerque c'est la même chose la
situation géographique de la métropole
frontalière de la Belgique qui est
proche des Pays-Bas qui est proche des
grands ports internationaux qui est
traversé par de nombreux axes
autoroutiers ça en fait un espace de
transit ça en fait une zone de stockage
et sen fait une zone de redistribution
euh bien que très présente à l'île et
notamment au niveau des portes de l'île
et bien c'est pas une la problématique
de la seule ville cent mais nous avons
de nombreuses communes périphérique qui
sont impactés avec différents types de
drogues qui sont vendues et consommé du
cannabis bien sûr essentiellement résin
et herb de l'héroïne de la cocaïne ainsi
que du craque un peu plus disparate et
fut moins répandu qu'à Paris mais qui
arrive dans le ressort des réseaux de
vente qui sont extrêmement organisés
hiérarchisé qui évolue bien sûr au fil
des contraintes et des ou des tendances
telles un commerce classique comme peut
en témoigner l'usage de plus en plus
fréquent des réseaux sociaux comme outil
publicitaire ou le développement dont on
vous a parlé de la livraison à domicile
le délinquant se fait entrepreneur et il
se fait même entrepreneur international
c'est très important pour lui notamment
pour blanchir c'est une criminalité
structurée en équipe qui se donne les
moyens de ces fins et ces fins sont
doubles c'est déjà une finalité
lucrative très rapide sans état d'âme et
puis une finalité de jouissance de son
enrichissement en empêchant les actions
répressives et judiciaires alors oui
nous constatons une appropriation de
l'espace public où s'affirme les codes
créés par les dealers euh avec des
des des prix des tarifs qui sont des des
appropriations de cage d'immeuble ce qui
entraîent une cohabitation avec les
habitants et peut-être de plus en plus
c'est difficile affirmer mais quand même
une cohabitation banalisée ces derniers
s'expriment peu et pourtant même s'ils
détiennent des informations partielles
et bien ces informations sont
essentielles et je vous reparlerai
peut-être de la la
de cette information leur silence
s'explique la plupart du temps par la
peur des représailles par la
méconnaissance des acteurs vers lesquels
ils peuvent se tourner vers une certaine
lassitude d'une partie de la population
qui ne croit plus en l'action des
pouvoirs publics alors s'agissant
toujours du bas du spectre ou de la
partie visible des trafics sur notre
territoire urbain trafic de plus en plus
visible dans l'espaceace public qui sont
implantés dans des espaces résidentiels
denses bien choisis pour leur
morphologie je dirais parce qu'ils
doivent permettre la surveillance par
les getteteurs et ils doivent permettre
la dispersion facile à l'arrivée des
forces de l'ordre et puis il y a une
coexistence quotidienne dans de mêmes
espaces entre les les dealers et les
habitants et ces derniers d'ailleurs
développent des connaissances parfois
très fines concernant les modalités de
l'organisation du trafic ainsi que le
déroulé de la vente de drogue alors je
pourrais citer la ville de l'os euh qui
accueille plus de 22000 habitants dans
un territoire bénéficiant d'une très
bonne
accessibilité notamment avec le
périphhérique deux secteurs sont touchés
par les problématiques de stupéfiant
l'un qui est composé principalement de
de logements sociaux et sujet à un
trafic mouvement de cannabis et l'autre
au sein d'une tour d'habitat social bien
connu qu'on appelle la tour de la mort
et qui est à côté de trois autres tours
plus sur sur l'agglomération sur l'île
nous avons également ville neuve d'Asque
4e ville la plusupée de la métropole qui
accueille un nombre important de
logements et nombreuses activités
génératrices de flux il y a deux grands
campus de l'université de lillele un
grand centre commercial le grand stade
des parcs d'activités elle est traversée
par deux lignes de métro et les trafics
de stupéfiants bien sont présents sur la
commune sont tournés principalement vers
la vente de cannabis et le quartier le
plus plus impacté et quand même à
proximité du campus universitaire même
si la problématique est également
présente de manière plus épars dans
divers secteurs de la ville ces trafics
je l'ai entendu implique des jeunes des
jeunes de plus en plus jeunes de 13 à 16
ans l'étude des dossiers et les
informations échangées lors de nos
réunions de travail ont permis quand
même de constater le fonctionnement
différent des trafiquants en fonction de
la localisation du trafic
dans certains quartiers ou dans
certaines résidences le trafic peut
rester animé à à tous les niveaux par
des habitants du quartier ce sont des
locaux avec des nourrices les
trafiquants se posent souvent en
alternative économique avantageuse pour
les habitants d'une population assez
vulnérable mais aussi pour les mineurs
les jeunes majeurs et les toxicomanes de
ces quartiers que les les trafiquants
recrutent donc comme nourrice comme
getteteur comme portier comme
distributeur de repas ou comme
organisateur de fil d'attente et puis
dans une proportion croissante de lieux
de trafic et bien les trafiquant on
recours à des mineurs ou des majeurs
d'autres quartiers d'autres villes ou
même d'autres départements qui sont
recrutés via les réseaux sociaux à la
journée à la semaine voire au mois alors
l'état de la menace se mesure aussi au
regard du haut niveau d'activité de la
section
girirs madame Girard procureur adjointe
et ench charge de la division économique
et financière et de la criminalité
organisée vous en parlera l'île est
l'une des h juridictions interrégionales
spécialisées de France son activité la
situe d'ailleurs en 3e position la
girirs a développé une intense activité
de coopération pénale internationale
elle dispose de frontières terrestres ou
maritime commune avec la Belgique avec
le Luxembourg avec le le Royaume-Uni et
nous avons un ressort qui est fortement
impacté par le trafic international de
stupéfiant et laagir consacre et depuis
2016 moi j'ai pris ce poste de procureur
en
2020 au moment du du premier confinement
mais elle consacre une part de plus en
plus importante de son activité au
trafic de stupéfiants qui sont
prédominants c'est une évolution à la
hausse et qui concerne principalement
les ports du Havre et de
dunkererque pour l'importation de
cocaïne en notant également euh nous
vous en reparlerons une tendance à la
hausse du poids des cargaisons de
cocaïne qui nous viennent notamment
d'Amérique du Sud historiquement laagirs
de lîle a pu saisir d'affaires
d'importation de stupéfiants par voie
routière depuis les Pays-Bas et la
Belgique que ce soit de la cocaïne de
l'héroïne ou de la pâte d'amphétamine
mais aussi en en provenance d'Espagne
pour l'herbe et la résine de cannabis à
destination du territoire français voire
à destination du Royaume-Uni et puis
elle a désormais développé une expertise
en matière d'importation de cocaïne par
voie maritime par frais de contenurisé
en provenance d'Amérique du Sud puisque
le port du Havre reste la principale
porte d'entrée de cocaïne sur le sol
français les saisies sont régulières
elle elles pent sur des cargaisons
importantes euh même si ne nous leuront
pas c'est une infime partie de la
réalité euh cependant on a quand même
l'émergence du port de der comme point
d'entrée secondaire qui constitue
désormais une préoccupation
majeure nous avons et Madame Gérard
pourra vous parler des procédés de
dissimulation les modes opératoires qui
sont très variés qui vous seront
synthétisés il est aussi quand même
important d'évoquer le dossier
encrochade qui est un une enquête
lilloise qui a permis d'identifier
l'existence d'une solution de
communication numérique chiffrée donc
distribué sous le nom commercial
encrochate à l'usage bien sûr
d'organisations criminelles de très haut
niveau de niveau international de niveau
national et international et les
téléphones chiffrés concernés étaient
présentés dans un circuit de
distribution d'une grande opacité et
distingue des circuits commerciaux
classiques en ce que ça garantissait aux
utilisateurs un parfait anonymat une
parfaite
confidentialité au téléphone et surtout
on garantit i au téléphone de n'être ni
traçable ni détectable alors les
investigations techniques ont permis de
constater que cette solution de
communication chiffré non déclaré en
France et bien était en fait euh mise en
circulation mise en œuvre depuis des
serveurs installés en France dans le
département du Nord à roubet au profit
d'une clientèle mondiale et
l'exploitation des données saisies on
parle quand même de plus de 115
millions de de de messages
euh a confirmé leur utilisation
notamment dans des grandes affaires
d'association malfaiteur de grande
envergure d'importation et de trafic de
quantité considérable de stupéfiants
mais aussi de trafic d'armes d'armes
lourdes ou de blanchiment et ce dossier
continue d' d'entraîner une une intense
activité de coopération internationale
avec près d'une quarantaine de pays des
échanges constants avec Eurojust et
Europort et ce dossier a permis
d'externaliser près d'une centaine de
procédures incidentes sur le le
territoire national parmi lesquels neuf
sont restés à la geirs de Lille alors
nous avons fait encore un bilan en juin
dernier de ce dossier des très
nombreuses opérations d'interpellation
intervenues dans les pays partenaires
avec des résultats significatifs des
saisies très importantes de stupéfiants
des centaines de milliers d'euros et des
armes lourdes et euh d'ailleurs et c'est
important parce que on va dire vous
séparez le la partie visible de la
partie du niveau de criminalité organisé
géré par le parquetgirs et lar girirs de
Lille mais dans le cadre de d'une de ces
procédures incidentes des échanges
particulièrement évocateur d'un trafic
de produits stupéfiants d'ampleur ont
notamment été détectés émanant
d'utilisateur qui apparaissaient sous de
des pseudonymes mais qui étaiit
justement localisé sur une tour de l'île
sud euh manifestement en charge de la
logistique et de l'approvisionnement du
trafic de stupéfiants la tour qui situe
à lî au 92 rue Flora Tristan qui est
plus connu sous l'appellation tour de
laabeu et qui est un gros point de deal
de la métropole lilloise euh qui semble
se calmer mais qui nous occupe depuis
assez longtemps dans l'un de nos plus
ancien groupe local de traitement de la
délinquence et ce dossier nous a permis
de comprendre comment fonctionne
ce point de vente dont le chiffre
d'affaires était quand même estimé à
40000 € par jour et qui a donné lieu à
plusieurs interpellations la dernière en
janvier 2023 euh c'était au total 138000
€ d'avoir criminel saisis aussi bien des
comptes bancaires du numéraire mais
également de la maroinerie de luxe de la
cryptoonnaie euh sans compter les
véhicules les montres Rolex je vous en
passe mais il y avait quand même la
saisi d'un bien immobilier àquis à dubaï
qui nous appartient maintenant de faire
exécuter euh à cela
s'ajoute une complexité croissante des
affaires aussi bien en terme de
technicité qu'en terme de volume ce sont
des dossiers chronophages des dossiers
qui sont composés de nombreux tomes
d'une très grande complexité et cette
criminalité pour reprendre les questions
qui vous intéresse génère bien sûr des
violences génère des homicides c'est la
multiple explication concernant le port
du Havre mais madame Girard y reviendra
d'ffets d'enlèvement de menaces ou
d'intimidation ainsi que des violences
graves qui visent les dockers ou leur
famille et on observe bien sûr une
montée en gravité de ces dossiers dans
certains dans plusieurs de nos dossiers
assez significatifs très
localement nous connaissons même si
c'est peu médiatisé des guerres de
territoire avec des règlements de compte
sous la forme de ce qu'on a appelé la
jambisation
puisque voilà on sort les armes et on
tire dans les G dans les dans les jambes
pardon des concurrents mais aussi de
plus en plus des tentatives d'homicide
et des homicides notamment l'île et
roubet
et dans la plupart de ces affaires de
trafic de stupéfiants et bien des armes
sont utilisées et des armes à l'occasion
des enquêtes sont
découvertes alors l'action répressive et
bien elle
a notamment eu pour effet
la
multiplication d'identification et et
d'interpellations d'agents par portuair
corrompu ainsi que la neutralisation de
de plusieurs organisations en charge de
la de la sortie des cargaisons de
cocaïne la la question des
compromissions portuaires demeure
prégante avec des rémunérations qui vont
de 20000 à 100000 € par opération il
convient aussi de de s'interroger quand
même sur la sécurisation des crèfes
pénitentiaires s'agissant en particulier
des actions corruptives qui sont
susceptibles d'être exercées sur des
agents de greffe pouvant permettre non
seulement des remises en liberté
frauduleuses voire le cas échéant la
réalisation
d'évasion grâce à cette compromission et
puis enfin la la sécurité intrinsèque
des lieu de détention mériterait d'être
garanti le brouillage systématique des
établissements pénitentiaires euh pour
empêcher quand même les trafiquants de
poursuivre leurs activités criminelles
en détention car c'est Mo ces derniers
disposent quand même de de moyens de
téléphonie qui leur permet de délivrer
des directives depuis leurs cellules euh
et euh à leurs affidés qui leur sont
totalement dévoués et qui sont de de
bons relais opérationnels sur le terrain
le ressort à notamment deux centres
pénitentiaires importants d'Elin et
cequedin qui sont surpeuplé qui AE2
représente un peu plus de 1600 détenus
et nous menons des actions avec
l'administration pénitencièr les
services de police et de gendarmerie
pour lutter contre les entrées
irrégulières de produits stupéfiants en
détention c'est une priorité de
politique pénale je ne parle pas
seulement des contrôles au niveau des
parloires euh mais des stratégies
d'enquête que nous devons mettre en
œuvre pour lutter contre les projections
à l'intérieur des établissements et
comme la délinquence ne cesse évoluer
techniquement et bien nous devons agir
désormais contre les livraisons par
drone au niveau même des
cellules madame Girard vous décrira les
actions menées par laagirs avec les
services de police et de gendarmerie
l'office l'ofaste et les offices
centraux les stratégies et techniques
d'enquête les techniques spéciales
d'enquête utilisé parfois obsolè parce
que souvent qui se révèlent inadapté aux
pratiques des trafiquants qui sont de
plus en plus pointus notamment en
matière de
cybercriminalité les méthodes de travail
sans oublier bien sûr la gestion des
sources humaines qui demeure parfois
sujette à interrogation de la part des
magistrats et le traitement du
renseignement humain on peut en effet
continuer à déplorer parfois certains
manques dans l'information des parquets
Gears notamment sur les sources humaines
ainsi que le fait que ces informations
nous sont délivrées souvent à cont-temps
notre besoin c'est un besoin d'in
formation aussi bien depuis les
quartiers moi j'ai dû mettre en œuvre
une une adresse mail à destination des
habitants qu'ils peuvent utiliser qu'ils
utilisent parfois même si l'omerte
arigne mais nous avons besoin d'un outil
partagé actualisé de cartographie des
lieux de trafic un suivi un suivi de la
localisation des faits objet des des
dossiers en cours d'enquête afin d'avoir
quand même non seulement une visibilité
sur l'origine des dossiers sur les
produits concerné sur les services
saisis et sur l'implantation
géographique du du trafic l'objectif est
de pouvoir apprécier la mobilité de ces
trafics ou au contraire leur
enracinement puisque c'est quand même
assez intéressant de voir qu'il y a des
endroits où le trafic perdure depuis
maintenant quelques années alors que les
cross constituent quand même un lieu
d'échange des informations privilégiées
sur le
narcobanditisme bien il est souvent
regretté par les magistrats du parquet
de ne pas y être associé dans la mesure
où où ces renseignements qui sont
échangés ont quand même vocation à la
fin être judiciarisé et le plus
intelligemment possible la lutte contre
les trafics stupéfiants passe aussi par
la capacité à produire de l'analyse
criminelle à opérer des rapprochements à
partager l'information et c'est déjà le
cas avec nos nos relations régulières
transparentes opérationnelles avec la
Jul alalco avec les parquets infragirs
avec les autres geirs
euh tu évoqueras le le bureau de liaison
portuaire qui offre là aussi une vraie
circulation de l'information entre les
parquets et cette circulation de
l'information elle est nécessaire elle
est engagée même avec les maires avec la
préfecture avec les bailleurs sociaux
les GLTD à un niveau bien moindre mais
un niveau important c'est des groupes
territorialisés des groupes thématiques
on le mérite de se réunir régulièrement
de faire le point et de conduire aussi
une une action judiciaire affinée
précise elle renseigne aussi l'élu local
elle permet à l'élu d'avoir des
informations et aussi des d'en aviser de
renseigner la population et puis notre
coopération judiciaire très
satisfaisante au plan européen notamment
avec les magistrat belge et néerlandais
et
euh nous bien sûr nous apprécions
l'appui d'Eurojust qui est essentiel
dans nos procédures hors cadre européen
mais Virginie reviendra la coopération
est plus délicate et ou plus variable
elle pourra aussi vous évoquer les
difficultés que nous pouvons
rencontrer avec la coopération avec
certains pays du Maghreb ou les Émirats
arabes unis dans lesquels d'ailleurs les
trafiquants de très haut niveau se
réfugient se mettent à l'abri des
mandats d'arrêts internationaux et aussi
peuvent y investir les produits de leur
activité criminelle voilà ce qui
contrarie davantage encore notre
politique de plus en plus ferme et
assidu de saisie et confiscation des
avoirs criminels mais là encore pour
saisir les avoirs criminels encore
faut-il avoir les capacités d'enquête
suffisantes des capacités d'enquête
approfondies renforcé pour les détecter
pour les localiser en France comme à
l'étranger voilà mais je pense que
ensuite nous pourrons également évoquer
nos pistes ou nos propositions d'amélior
tion je ne vais pas en dire davantage
pour l'instant je vous remercie Monsieur
Merci beaucoup madame la procureur
madame Gérard je vous propose de
d'enchaîner je vous remercie monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames et Messieurs les
les les sénateurs au titre des constats
que vous nous avez invité à à faire sur
l'état de de la menace j'aurai une
intervention qui sera orientée sur deux
axes d'une part les appréciations que je
peux formuler au titre enfin au plan
local sur l'état des lieux du du
narcotrafic dans le ressort de lîle et
puis d'autre part les de la menace tel
qu'on peut l'appréhender à l'échelon de
de l'interrégion alors le poids du
contentieux du du trafic de stupéfiant
sur le ressort interrégional lillois
laisse apparaître des des organisations
criminelles qui sont polyvalentes en
produits ainsi qu'en en compéten
logistique mais pas au sens où elle
générerait des champs criminels
diversifiés notre regard sur la
criminalité du haut spectre conduit nous
conduit plutôt à à relever une
abrication d'activités délinquant euh
qui sont distinctes entre elles euh mais
qui coopèrent par opportunisme il y a
notamment à titre d'exemple euh on peut
citer les les garages clandestins ou les
garages fantômes qui est un phénomène
qui est extrêmement important sur sur
roubé euh ainsi que les trafiquants de
de véhicules qui offrent euh des
supports logistiques précieux euh par le
truchement d'immatriculation au CIV
alors on sait que le CIV constitue une
faille majeure à la faveur de la
dématérialisation euh de des
ématriculations et du fait aussi que des
sociétés ont été créées adoc pour
permettre de manière frauduleuse
d'immatriculer des flottes de véhicules
qui vont permettre B mout infractions
mais en particulier la facilitation du
traffic de de stupéfiants et également
la constitution de société de location
de véhicules de complaisance qui sont
également utilisé par les réseaux de
trafic de stupéfiants qui sont parfois
eux-mêmes implantés fort loin du
territoire lillois donc on voit aussi
cette espèce d'attrait que peut
constituer le le le territoire le
territoire lillois alors quelques mots
pour commencer des réseaux de la la
métropole plus plusieurs procédures et
de longue date ont démontré le le
développement sur le secteur lillois et
roubéien de réseaux criminels qui sont
donc implantés et spécialisé dans le
transport international de produits
stupéfiants donc très classiquement
produits qui sont obtenus au Pays-Bas en
Belgique et en Espagne pas seulement à
destination du du marché de
l'interrégion mais également de
l'ensemble du territoire national c'estd
aussi les capacités de redistribution
que l'on peut observer et de fait la
grande proximité la grande disponibilité
des produits leur grande qualité parce
qu'il faut dire que les produits de
titre à un très très bon taux
l'attractivité des des tarifs positionne
certains réseaux liloin euh comme de
vrais opérateurs internationaux je crois
qu'il faut pas se lurer et se dire
qu'effectivement on a AFF faire au haut
du spectre des capacités logistiques
particulièrement développé ont été
également observés euh capacité de
recrutement capacité de recrutement
d'une main d'œuvre quasiment inépuisable
et qui recour à la violence dans les
règlements de compte avec leur leurs
concurrents certains de ces trafiquants
locaux hein lillois entretiennent des
contacts directs avec les
narcotrafiquants qui sont inscrits au
top 25 national mais aussi avec des
fournisseurs étrangers ce qui les
positionne clairement dans le haut du
spectre et puis ces organisations sont
en capacité aussi d'organiser à l'avance
leur impunité on note par exemple que
les chefs de réseau procèdent parfois à
la désignation des avocats pour leur
subordonné ce qui induit un verrouillage
de la parole se font le cas échéant
adresser des compte-rendus des
procédures judiciaires en temps réel euh
donc vous notez la puissance de ces
organisations qui se donnent aussi à
voir par leur capacités corruptive
majeure j'en parlerai un petit peu plus
loin on peut évoquer aussi le quartier
du du pont de bois à ville neudasque qui
est un petit peu différente dans sa
typicité puisque le profil des
narcotrafiquants est celui d'individu
très jeune désinsérés qui véhiculent
plus ou moins les les codes classiques
du rap le culte de la personnalité
l'exhibition des armes de l'argent des
véhicules et cetera le tout dans des
clips là encore avec un un mélange un
peu inquiétant entre le propos
artistique et le le véhicule
publicitaire à des fins à des fins de de
commercialisation ce qu'il faut noter en
tout cas sur ces sur ces sur ces groupes
c'est que il se caractérise par une très
forte immaturité qui a pour corelaire
aussi l'extrême violence dont ils font
preuve il y a eu des morts notamment à
la faveur de leurs agissements et
évidemment le risque de victime
collatérale je voudrais ensuite évoquer
les trafics portuair parce que comme on
vous l'a dit le port du Havre et la
porte d'entrée principale des produits
stupéfiants en France euh et ça nous
concerne évidemment au plus haut point
euh si 60 % du contentieux de l'agire
c'est constitué par les dossiers de
trafic de stupéfiants ces dossiers là en
eux-mêm émanent pour environ 80 %
d'entre eux du port et du parquet du du
Havre donc c'est vous donner une idée de
de l'ampleur de ces de ces de ces
dossiers alors euh ce principe enfin le
principal phénomène qui impacte
d'interrégion lilloise il est constitué
donc par ses importations de cocaïne qui
svent sur la zone portuaire avreise avec
euh désormais un second point de
préoccupation qui est le port de duner
et j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure place
occupée par le port du du Havre qui
s'explique évidemment par sa
localisation privilégiée il faut vous
rappeler si vous ne le savez pas le
parcours contreintuitif des navires qui
venant d'Amérique du Sud vont d'abord
faire escale à Hambourg à Rotterdam à
enverse avant de toucher les ports
français ce qui pour nous peut
constituer du reste un un atout en tout
cas ça fait du Havre ça permet pour les
les trafiquants d'en faire une
utilisation alternative au grand port
que je viens de que je viens de citer ou
la pression des services de sécurité et
des autres organisations criminelles
concurrentes ou parasite puisqu'il y a
aussi des phénomènes d'appropriation des
des cargaisons peut con
conjoncturellement s'avérer dissuasive
donc le port du Havre permet aux
narcotrafiquants de s'émanciper de la
présence d'autres organisations et en
faisant moins jouer la concurrence de
maximiser les rémunération c'est un
double c'est un double intérêt euh les
éléments qui ont été recueillis dans le
cadre de la l'exploitation des données
issue de la procédure en crochchat qui a
donc été initié et suivi par la la gerse
de l'île à compté de de 2020 confirme la
très grande maîtrise par les
organisations criminelles des routes
logistiques maritimes euh leur capacité
à se réorganiser dans des temps record
notamment quand les débouchés portuaires
ne sont pas assurés leur grande faculté
aussi à corrompre les agents qui
pourront offrir les sorties portuaire
ces éléments recueillis mettent
également en lumière leur opportunisme
qui les amène euh a adapté
systématiquement leur coopération avec
d'autres organisations ainsi que leurs
modes opératoires donc une agilité de
ces organisations qui les rend
effectivement difficiles à à attaquer
les procédures en crochchat et je je je
pourrais extrapoler aussi pour la
procédure Sky qui en fait avait aussi
pour origine la juridiction lilloise
mais qui a été qui a donné lieu à un
dessaisissement et à son traitement par
par la junalco ont du reste démontrer
que ces organisations criminelles
cherchent volontairement à saturer les
services portuaires euh ces
organisations ne craignent absolument
pas de sacrifier d'importantes quantités
de produits supéfiant dont dont elles
savent qu'il qu'elles seront saisies
tandis que des quantités plus
importantes encore pourront dans le même
temps échapper euh aux douanes notamment
qui sont justement occupés à à effectuer
les les saisies il faut vous le dire des
conversations interceptées démontrent le
mépris et le détachement absolu avec
lesquels les organisations criminelles
euh notent ou constatent euh les saisies
douanièr ou ou policière ce qui démontre
là encore leur force de frappe leur
puissance cri financière et leur
capacité à inonder le le marché le
marché européen alors j'évoquerai un peu
plus loin la recrudescence notable du
phénomène des des enlèvements et des
séquestrations qui est notamment en lien
avec la problématique portuaire avrez et
qui est en fait inscrite d'assez longue
date dans ce ce
paysage territorial pas seulement dans
la dans la scène maritime et qui tend
qui tend à à à se à se à s'étendre en
tout en tout cas on note une montée en
gravité des dossiers j'évoquerai le
dossier afagar qui a été jugé en
septembre en septembre dernier on note
aussi une montée en gamme observé sur
les les les profils ciblés et aussi une
montée en gamme par le mode de
résolution financier qui a pu être
établi à la faveur de certains dossiers
par les services enquêteurs notamment
s'agissant du montant des rançons qui
sont en capacité d'être payés d'être
mobilisés et ce dans des temps records
notamment en ayant recours à des
paiements depuis l'étranger à des modes
de compensation qui font quand même
penser ni plus ni moins que au mode au
mode de la wala et cetera qu'on peut
qu'on peut évoquer donc les finalités de
ces enlèvements évidemment elles sont
multiples ça peut être la recherche de
de renseignement ou la coopération pour
une future sortie portuaire ça peut être
également le vol de liquidité ça peut
être des lictiges commerciaux entre
trafiquants voir des des représailles le
port de dkerc constitue aux yeux de
laagir un angle mort et un sujet de
préoccupation absolument majeur euh on a
eu des dossiers euh de saisie mais
l'actuelle euh faiblesse des
constatations sur le site de d'unkererc
est révélatrice à nos yeux de
l'insuffisance des moyens de ciblage et
de détection des flux de cocaïne alors
même que nous avons des nouvelles lignes
maritimes euh qui sont régulièrement
ouvertes et alors que je l'évoqué un peu
plus en en amont des risques euh de
pollution existent euh en fonction des
ports rebonds que j'évoqué sur le Range
le Range de de la mer du Nord donc cette
absence de saisie conduit également à
s'interroger sur l'existence de
compromission de haut niveau c'est une
conviction mais qui n'est pas étayée en
tout cas c'est une interrogation euh que
nous nous faisons et puis il faut
rappeler quand même que dunerc constitue
le premier port français d'importation
des fruits exotiques et ce depuis 2019
et ce fret légal est traditionnellement
en tout cas régulièrement utilisé pour
les importations de cocaïne c'est un
vecteur assez naturel les organisations
criminelles opèent depuis l'étranger
recrutent en région parisienne ou dans
les Haut- de- France des équipes de
récupérateurs euh parfois peu chevronné
mais qui n'hésite pas aussi à user de
mode de récupération extrêmement violent
on a vu des dépottages en pleine voie de
circulation dans les rues du Havre on a
vu des arrachages de stupéfiants d'un
conteneur dans la cour d'enceinte d'une
société avec le véhicule des
récupérateurs qui n'hésite pas à foncer
sur un employé donc des méthodes
extrêmement
violentes qui montrent la détermination
des des des acteurs vous nous avez
interrogé sur la la criminalité connexe
j'allais dire je vais vous parler
d'abord de la criminalité induite et de
la criminalité euh connexe puisque
l'évocation des des violences auxquelles
ont recour les les équipes de
collecteurs ou de récupérateurs me
conduit assez naturellement à aborder
cette criminalité qui est induite par le
trafic de stupéfiants euh les règlements
de compte notamment mais aussi le
blanchiment euh s'agissant des
règlements de compte au sens large euh
la section de laagirs en particulier a
eu à connaître d'atteintte aux personnes
extrêmement graves et qui à nos yeux
vont créchin d'eau euh il y AEL quelques
années on évoqué le phénomène des des
jambisations donc c'est des
avertissements qui pouvent être
délivré et sous forme et avisé non non
létal désormais ce sont des des
assassinats auxquels nous nous assistons
deux exemples à Lille en 2021
l'exécution sur la voie publique dans
une rue située à à peine 200 m du
tribunal judiciaire de de lîle d'un
jeune homme mineur qui était mis en
examen dans une affaire de stupéfiant et
dont l'environnement a révélé
l'existence de tension très forte sur
fond de sur fond de trafic autre exemple
à roubé en 2021 l'assassinat d'un homme
déjà lourdement contamné condamné
atteint de balles dans le dos et à la
tête on peut également citer à titre
d'illustration les diverses méthodes qui
sont utilisés par les trafiquants à
l'encontre de leurs concurrents ou de
ceux qu'ils considèrent comme des
traîtres
euh alors par exemple une tentative de
meurtre d'un individu qui sortait de la
maison d'arrêt euh de ce queedin des
tirs à l'arme lourde en pleine journée
donc sur le parking de cette maison
d'arrêt alors que des familles
attendaient au demeurant les parloires
qui visaiit un individu dont la date de
libération était connu du clan ennemi
sur un fond de différents évidemment lié
au trafic de stupéfiants euh également
un meurtre en bande organisé commis par
une organisation originaire de de roubet
il s'agissait de représail par un
important trafiquant du Nord de la
France envers l'un de ses subordonnés
qui lui avait dérobé de l'argent lors
d'un transp pardon lors d'un transport
de Somme considérabl en en voiture et là
je le cite parce queil s'agit d'une euh
d'un cas de figure un peu exceptionnel
puisqu'il s'agissait d'un barbecue ce
qui est une méthode très peu usitée dans
le nord de la France à la différence du
du du Sud et et de Marseille le cas
échéant qui témoigne quand même d'une
volonté d'assoir une autorité de
dissuader toute véléité de trahison ou
d'autonomisation des membres de
l'organisation au dépend des têtes de
réseau des enlèvements et séquestration
notamment à à roubay sur instruction
d'un trafiquant de de de stupéfiants
originaire de de roubet l'enlèvement par
quatre individus et en plein
centre-ville d'un individu soupçonné
d'une somme de0000 € dans le cadre du
trafic de stupéfiants individu qui est
mis dans un coffre déshabillé qui se
voit placer une arme sur la tempe et qui
est finalement relâché après
confiscation de ses papiers d'identité
par l'un des participants puisque ce
dernier était sous contrôle judiciaire
et était tout à fait désireux de se
dissimuler des autorités donc l'enquête
a révélé du reste l'utilisation
régulière de cette méthode dans la
gestion des des conflits un autre cas
qui est que je je voudrais citer c'est
l'enlèvement d'un mineur sur la commune
de Saint-Quentin dans l'aine alors qu'il
se rendait au collège sa séquestration
pendant 48 heures sous fond différent
commercial entre trafiquant de de de
stupéfiant là encore des des des choses
qui sont tout à fait significatives et
je ne voudrais pas non plus oublier de
mentionner l'inflation des règlements de
compte qui apparaît également très
nettement sur
Amien récemment en avril 2023 une équipe
de trois individus et pénétré a pénétré
au domicile de de deux personnes attiré
sur deux frère euh tuant l'un d'eux et
blessant sérieusement le le le second
tous ces dossiers c'est des dossiers
dont l'AG est saisi et de la même
manière dans les procédures Avre on note
le recours à des enlèvements à des
séquestrations à des violences et à des
services graves à l'encontre de docker
ou de leurs proches qui le cas échéant
ont pu conduire à la mort et c'est
notamment le dossier afagar qui a
défrayé la la chronique enlèvement d'un
dockur qui avait été précédemment mise
en examen dans le cadre d'un dossier
d'importation de cocaïne par voie
portuaire à laagirce de lillele vitime
retrouvé sans vie après avoir été
l'objet de de de violence grave qui on
entraîné son son décès on a juger cette
affaire dans le cadre d'une de poursuite
du chef d'association de de malfaiteurs
récemment d'autres dossiers à vrai sont
relatifs à des donc à des enlèvements
suivi de violence grave ou encore à des
menaces à des extorsions mais aussi des
braquages parfois en plein centre-ville
avec des véhicules qui sortent du port
chargé de de pain de de pain de cocaïne
donc le phénomène de ces séquestration
est révélateur de l'ultraviolence à
laquelle recours les membres de ces
réseaux il faut évidemment j'y insiste
mentionner l'omerta qui règne sur le
monde des dockur qui entrave
considérablement l'action policière
c'est un phénomène qui est quand même
souvent dissimulé les familles ne
signalent les disparitions qu'en
dernière extrémité au moment des
demandes de de rançon qu'ils ont parfois
des difficultés à à régler les victimes
conservent le silence par peur de
représail euh par volonté euh le cas
échéant de se faire justice elle-même
mais aussi parce qu'elle ne souhaite pas
éveiller les soupçons des enquêteurs
quant à leur implication éventuelle dans
la facilitation de sortie portuaire ou
ne souhait pas révéler leur lien avec
des tiers qui ont eux- même participer à
ce type de à ce type de sortie et puis
enfin à noter l'enlèvement la
séquestration d'un dokerer d'unkerercois
en cet été 2023 qui a également été
victime d'A de d'acte de torture donc
vous voyez un phénomène qui tend à à
s'élargir deuxième point c'est
s'agissant du du blanchiment euh c'est
un point fondamental à mes yeux et je
crois que le constat doit être opéré
d'une faiblesse structurel de nos moyens
d'enquête pour détecter pour identifier
pour saisir et confisquer les fonds les
fonds blanchis à la faveur du trafic de
stupéfiants plusieurs raisons à cela
d'abord la plasticité des modèles de
blanchiment euh leur caractère
mondialisé et il faut le dire aussi la
relative faiblesse de nos services de
nos services d'enquêteur nos services
enquêteurs euh il y a une intrication
des organisations criminelles euh réseau
de trafiquant euh avec d'une part avec
des organisations criminelles qui elles
sont spécialisées dans les blanchiments
de toute nature et de toute origine et
on voit des collusions frauduleuses et
des des des des conjonctions entre
différentes organisations le recours à
des modes de blanchiment traditionnels
que sont la wala et le recours au au
Saraf avec des systèmes de compensation
pour lequel l'argent n'effectue aucun
déplacement physique ça implique des
méthodes d'enquête très particulières
aussi une une connaissance bah qui n'est
pas forcément celle des enquêteurs
dédiés à la lutte contre le trafic de
stupéfiant mais qui est plutôt celle
développé par le sogdf notamment dans
certains dossiers qui qui sont peut-être
connus de de de votre commission
d'enquête déjà il y a il y a plusieurs
années le recours au crypto au
cryptoactifs est est également un écueil
puisque l'appréhension de ces
cryptoactifs justifie une formation
assez poussée notamment des des des
services enquêteurs et puis le recours à
d'autres méthodes de blanchiment qui
peuvent être le recours à des sociétés
taxis ou des ou à des léiveuses et qui
implique là encore et bien que les
services financiers que les services
enquêteurs spécialisés en matière
financière et bien s s'y a-t-elle donc à
mon sens ces services n'apparaissent pas
suffisamment armés pour travailler de
manière parallèle et concomitante au fil
au démantelllement des filières de de
trafic de stupéfiants concomitante pour
l'appréhension des modes de de
blanchiment je crois qu'il y a à la fois
une faiblesse des effectifs une
structuration dépassée des services
enquêteurs avec une division
traditionnelle et pour tout dire à mon
avis archaïque d'émission dévolu dévolu
au au service une solution qui a pu être
évoquée devant vous par nos collègues
parisiens et qui a été mise en œuvre par
leurs soins que nous allons également
dupliquer consiste à recourir aux
dispositions de l'article
324-11 du Code de Procédure du code
pénal pardon c'est-à-dire la le recours
à la notion de présomption de
blanchiment euh je je je n'y reviens pas
parce que je pense que vous avez été
suffisamment éclairé sur sur ce point
mais en tout état de cause euh il s'agit
de de de de de se fonder sur des
conditions matérielles financières ou
juridiques qui permettent de considérer
ben que l'opération ne peut avoir
d'autres just ctification que la
dessimulation de l'origine ou du
bénéficiaire effectif de de l'opération
donc c'est un un levier extrêmement
utile en conclusion sur ce point alors
même que l'ensemble de nos procédures
d'information du chef de trafic de
stupéfiants vise également le
blanchiment c'est-à-dire que les
magistrats des parquets euh saisissent
systématiquement dans les dossiers de
trafic de stup euh les juges
d'instruction pour instruire sur le
volet blanchiment il ne reste pas moins
que l'on déplore une absence de caisine
euh avec les services financiers en
matière financière euh des
investigations qui sont principalement
axées sur une photographie des
patrimoines et une mise à jour des seuls
mécanismes de blanchiment les plus
simples et souvent du reste de manière
un peu partielle et donc il faut aussi
souligner à la décharge des services
enquêteurs que la typicité de nos
dossiers d'importation de stupéfiants
dans lesquels nos donneurs d'ordr sont
établis à l'étranger ne facilit
évidemment pas l'exercice vous nous avez
interroger également sur les cas de de
corruption et souhaitz recueillir notre
avis sur les les hypothèses de de
corruption d'agents publics ou privés
euh vous l'avez vu la puissance de ces
organisations criminelles leur permet
euh d'orénavant de de bénéficier de
complicité d'agents privés et publics
euh pour mémoire on peut évoquer les
phénomènes de compromission euh du
milieu professionnel des agents
portuaires des rémunérations
particulièrement élevées euh pour euh la
commission d'acte illicite euh 20000 €
pour un chauffeur euh 50000 € pour un
chauffeur de cavalier qui va déplacer un
conttainur pour euh faciliter une sortie
euh jusqu'à 100000 € euh évoqués dans
dans les dossiers euh des agents privés
tels que les dirigeants d'entreprises de
transport peuvent également être
approchés afin de faciliter le trafic et
la récupération des stupéfiants loin des
zones portuaires et puis s'agissant des
agents publics nos éléments de
conviction se forgent sur les à la
lecture des des dossiers et on peut
considérer comme exposé les catégories
de personnes suivantes les agents
pénitentiaires à l'évidence surveillant
greffe pénitentia à la fois pour la
remise de moyens de communication à des
détenus évidemment les les les
téléphones mais surtout pour l'obtention
via des erreurs de procédure
volontairement mis en œuvre par les
agents qui seraient approchés par
exemple des sollicitations pour mal
orienter ou pour ne pas transmettre dans
les délais des demandes de mise en
liberté ou des actes d'appel voire le
cas échéant la fabrication de faux qui
contribueraiit à des remises en liberté
donc des actions corruptives qui pourrai
permettre non seulement des remise en
liberté frauduleuse mais le cas échéant
on peut imaginer aussi la réalisation
d'évasion grâce à la compromission de ce
de ce milieu pit cire il faut noter et
là encore c'est tout à fait éloquent que
certains de nos trafiquants sont
particulièrement remplus à la procédure
pénale davantage même que leur conseil
pour certains et donne ne se privent pas
de donner des conseils à des tiers qu'il
soi leurs affidés ou leurs amis pour
trouver des moyens de pousser à la faute
les agents pénitentiaires donc vous avez
des gens qui sont parfaitement rompus à
l'exercice fonctionnaires de police ou
de gendarmerie pour la consultation de
fichierers afin de détecter des enquêtes
en cours et d' d'entraver les
investigation consultation CIV
consultation faues consultation du
statut des mises en cause par
exemple un dossier dans lequel et bien
un membre d'un service d'investigation
qui n'appartenait pas justement pardon à
un service d'investigation approché par
des narcotrafiquants pour consulter le
FPR le fichier des personnes recherchées
pour le compte de commanditair qui sont
désireux de savoir quel est le nombre de
mandats qui sont décerné contre eux là
aussi pour ensuite jouer des facilités
procédurales les douaniers pour la
facilitation du passage et de la sortie
portuaire des des marchandises les
agents de préfecture pour la
facilitation des immatriculations de
véhicules l'obtention de permis de
conduire la délivrance de papi
d'identité ou autre et puis il faut
évoquer aussi le possible rôle qui
serait susceptible des joué par les
avocats dans la corruption notamment
d'agents pénitentiaire j'ai cité tout à
l'heure le faux acte d'appel créer
toutes pièces rémunérer plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'euros ayant
abouti à la libération d'un prévenu et
puis au demeurant il faut éroger parfois
peut-être certaines pratiques de
certains avocats en ce qu'elles sont à
la limite de la bonne foi dans
l'exercice des voies procédurales euh
les liens entretenus avec laaginalco
j'en dirais deux mots pour vous indiquer
que ces relations sont très régulières
qu'elles se signal par leur fluidité la
réactivité la qualité des échanges
opérationnels qui ont lieu quasiment au
quotidien entre nous et de manière
informelle par mail téléphone ou
visioconférence et de manière plus
institutionnalisée à la faveur des
réunions annuel euh qui nous regroupe et
qui
sont présidés par la la junalco au titre
de son rôle de de coordination en
matière de trafic de stupéfiants il est
habituel pour les magistrats qui se
connaissent qui forment un réseau bien
identifié d'échanger sur nos objectifs
prioritaires qui peuvent être des
objectifs partagés par les geirs et par
la ginalco d'échanger sur les
dessaisissements sur les logiques de
dessaisissement d'une d'une procédure
enfin d'une juridiction à une autre mais
aussi de procéder à des retours
d'expérience nous avons eu euh parfois
nous avons pu rencontrer diverses
déconvenus en matière de livraison
surveillée douanière ou de livraison
surveillée
internationale et il est c'est un lieu
d'échange notamment sur la sécurité
juridique des des des des procédures des
réflexions sont également menées pour
tendre vers l'élaboration d'une doctrine
d'une doctrine pardon commune JIRS
junalco en matière de gestion des
sources humaines et ce aussi au constat
des nouvelles doctrines d'emploi de la
dood et de la dnrd et puis enfin la très
bonne communication existante entre les
les Gears permet également le cas
échéant de faire échec à des possibles
défauts d'information émanant des
services enquêteurs elle permet de
confronter nos point de vue de magistrat
quant au montage des des dossiers quant
à la gestion des sources et de
décloisonner le traitement du du
renseignement un petit mot sur le bureau
de liaison portuire qui offre une vraie
circulation de l'information entre les
les parquets qui était qui est de nature
également à faciliter la détermination
de l'agir la mieux positionné dans
l'hypothèse par exemple de saisie de
stupéfiants sèches qui sont réalisés au
Havre mais dont on constate qu'elles
intéressent au plus haut point les
dossiers de Fort de France pour nourrir
et abonder les procédures qui sont qui
sont menées menées par cette par cette
Geers donc le BDL permet aussi de se
garantir contre d'éventuels défauts de
transmission spontané d'information et
puis évidemment le dialogue entre
lesgers et la junalco a été nourri et
renforcé dans le cadre des
échanges sur le fond des des procédures
en crotchat et Sky Sky ECC un bref mot
sur sur les l'action de la gendarmerie
et celle de de la police nationale
puisque vous nous interrogiez à cet
égard euh évidemment le parquet joue un
rôle essentiel puisque c'est lui qui
détermine le cadre des des saisines
judiciaire et l'articulation entre les
services euh notamment s'agissant des
caisines et il faut le dire si la
pratique des caisines entre
l'antenneophaste du Havre et la SR la
section de recherche de Rin ne pose
aucune difficulté en revanche le
principe de la caésine euh entre
l'antenne faste de Lille avec laasr de
lillele euh demeure extrêmement euh
extrêmement délicate il y a donc des
difficultés euh dont il reste à voir si
elles persisteront à la faveur de la
réforme territoriale de la police
nationale en tout état de cause euh le
le les antennes offastes du du Havre et
de l'île constituent nos interlocuteurs
naturels euh il faut noter que l'ofast a
développé un savoir-faire et une
parfaite expertise de la pratique des
livraisons surveillées internationale
avec substitution fait montre d'une très
haute technicité comme de capacités
opérationnelles qui sont rapidement
mobilisable un bémol peut-être c'est un
bémol général puisqu'il n'en demeure pas
moins que les services enquêteurs n'ont
pas tous encore acquis le réflexe de
sollicité l'appuis d'Europol et que
peut-être il faut faire encore un
constat général d'un manque de culture
vers l'international de la part des
services de la part des services
enquêteurs et puis un autre bémol fait
par la l'agce de Lille c'est le constat
peut-être d'un recours insuffisant de la
part des services office centraux
compris à l'infiltration à la captation
et dans une moindre mesure à la
sonorisation et peut-être à cet écart
conviendrait-il d'envisager un budget
spécifique au niveau dn dnpz ou DGGN
pour développer le recours à ces à ces
techniques spéciales d'enquête qui sont
encore peut-être trop peu utilisé un
autre cadre de réflexion il nous
paraîtrait nous le cas échéant opportun
d'envisager une autre coordination du
système de notation des opepj au sein
des offices centraux en sollicitant les
magistrats des girirs par exemple qui
ont à connaître de leur activité au plan
international je vais passer très
rapidement puisque la coopération
européenne est extrêmement satisfaisante
laagerss a développé une longue
tradition une longue habitude et une
véritable expertise de de de coopération
avec les parquets belges et néerlandais
notamment dans le cadre des décisions
d'enquête européenne qui sollicite la
mise en œuvre de de livraison surveillé
ave avec substitution avec enverse ou
Rotterdam les magistrats de liaison en
Belgique en Allemagne et au Pays-Bas
constituent des rel précieux l'appui d'
rustes est pour nous fondamental il est
extrêmement précieux notamment dans les
procédures qui sont suivis à laagirs et
qui implique la coordination entre plus
de deux états et vraiment pour nous
c'est un lieu une instance de de de
dialogue de partage d'information un
soutien extrêmement extrêmement riche
ailleurs dans le monde on peut formuler
les observations suivantes avec
l'Amérique du Sud l'entraide pénale
internationale est variable euh si on
arrive tout à fait à effectuer des
livraisons surveillées internationales
avec le Brésil et la Colombie sans
difficulté l'exécution des demandes
d'entraide pénale internationale demeure
plus variable euh ça dépend un petit peu
de la la nature des choses demandées
puis avec des des délais de d'exécution
qui sont qui sont variables et je ne
vais pas me répéter mais effectivement
le parquet de l' l'agirs constate des
difficultés de coopération avec certains
des états du Maghreb les
Émirats les Émirats arabes unis
notamment pour les raisons qu'on vous a
déjà déjà exposé il faudra évidemment
envisager de de renforcer mais c'est
déjà le cas la coopération euh je ne
sais pas si j'ai le temps parce que je
vois que leur leur r tourne euh je
voulais vous évoquer l'ensemble des
objectifs et des actes de progression
que nous avons recensé à la fois au plan
législatif au plan des des moyens
humains et pour les services
d'enquêteurs et pour les pour les
magistrats au plan législatif il faut
d'abord je crois faire le constat que
les les techniques spéciales d'enquête
traditionnell c'està-dire les
interceptions téléphoniques sont
absolument obsolètes sont totalement
inefficaces elles sont plus plus du tout
adapté aux pratiques des trafiquants qui
échangent via la data moi je persiste à
dire que il serait souhaitable de rendre
possible l'infection à distance et de
permettre l'instauration de cheval de 3
des téléphones pour permettre la
captation de Data et l'utilisation par
les
narcotrafiquants de WhatsApp signal
Viber telgram ou ou snapchat la
possibilité de les les déchiffrer parce
que il faut quand même noter que de
manière générale les services d'enquête
et l'autorité judiciaire ont toujours un
temps de retard sur les modes
opératoires qui sont déployés par les
organisations criminelles au plan
européen il serait souhaitable peut-être
d'envisager la création d'un cadre
procédural unique de type retenu qui
permettrait à une autorité étrangère de
faire échec à une tentative de fuite euh
de nos individus placés en France sous
contrôle judiciaire avec interdiction de
quitter le territoire national français
mais qui dispose de faux documents et de
faciliter la transmission en temps réel
des informations avec l'État demandeur
donc par exemple l'État français et de
créer un cadre harmonisé de privation de
liberté provisoire permettant ainsi de
solliciter la remise de l'intéressé et
de garantir sa représentation en justice
il y a aussi certainement la nécessité
peut-être de réécrire certaines
dispositions textuelles ou de légiférer
sur certains points par par exemple une
remise à plat des textes en matière
d'enlèvement et séquestration l'abandon
de la notion de libération de plus ou
moins 7 jours pourra être envisagé un un
toilettage du texte qui pourrait
conduire à la criminalisation de
l'ensemble de ces faits d'enlèvement et
de séquestration dès lors qu'ils sont
commis en bande organisée qui nous
paraîtrait éviter un ce ce constat de
l'inutile complexité des qualifications
pénales en cette en cette matière des
clarifications attendues des textes
relatif d'une part à la facturation
détaillée je sais que la junalco vous en
a vous en a parlé mais aussi au régime
relatif à la la captation d'images dans
les lieux publics puisque actuellement
ce sont les parquets qui les autorise
sur le le le visa des dispositions du
code de procédure pénale et des
clarifications seraient attendues euh
moi je milite encore et toujours pour la
création d'un dédié spécialisé au
geirs et d'une filiarisation de la
juridiction de l'application des peines
pour connaître de ces profils qui sont
des profils extrêmement particuliers
puisque déjàg spécialisé serait
davantage en capacité de prendre acte
des éléments cruciaux que sont les
interpellations sur mandat d'arrêt les
conditions d'une cavale les
concertations frauduleuses les incidents
dans la durant le temps de la détention
provisoire étant prisé que l'ensemble de
nos profils geirs ont en apparence en en
détention des parcours extrêmement
lisses extrêmement enfin absolument
parfaits qui leur permettent de
bénéficier aisément euh d'aménagement de
peine et donc là il serait utile de
mettre en en en en corelire et en exerg
euh et bien ces ces éléments de de
parcours pénal et puis là aussi au plan
des moyens dédiés au services d'enquête
des interrogations sur la mise en œuvre
de la réforme territoriale de la police
évidemment la question de la détection
des avoirs criminels le renforcement des
capacités opérationnelles de traitement
des des dossiers sous l'angle du
blanchiment de de de trafic de de
stupéfiant je pense qu'il est
indispensable que l'ensemble des
services enquêteurs notamment en lofaste
soit doté de renforts en en enquêteur
financier il m' paraît également
indispensable de faire des Gires de
véritables services dédié aux enquêtes
patrimoniales j'ai le sentiment pour ma
part que les Gires ont été un peu dévoyé
constittu un outil presque exclusivement
dévolue au saisis alors que du côté des
geirs nous nous disposons de la grass
que nous disposons de la piaque qui
remplissent déjà cet office et que
concrètement les magistrats des Gears
sont déjà suffisamment rompus à la
pratique des des saisies pénales donc ce
qui nous manque c'est davantage des
services enquêteurs dédiés à la
réalisation de véritabl enquêtes
patrimonial et puis enfin au plan des
moyens dédiés à l'autorité judiciaire le
renforcement de l'équipe autour du des
magistrats pas simplement pour dire que
il faut des assistants spécialisés cyber
douiniers fiscaux comptables mais parce
que ces assistants par leur expertise
sont en capacité en
parallèle des services enquêteurs de
diligenter des investigations de manière
autonome sur certains aspects des des
dossiers donc de soulager les services
enquêteurs et d'accélérer le rythme des
des investigations c'est extrêmement
précieux pour cela il faut évidemment
pérenniser le statut de ces assistants
spécialisés de leur offrir une formation
qui soit pas une formation artisanale
sous lesgide des des magistrats qui ne
repose pas uniquement sur l'engagement
des magistrats en juridiction mais qui
soit bel et bien labellisé par l'École
nationale de la magistrature qui leur
permettent justement d'être rapidement
opérationnel et puis peut-être enfin
parce que les effectifs et les les les
capacités humaines sont une chose mais
évidemment il faudrait permettre encore
à l'air de rendre accessible et effectif
au sein des GES le recours à des
solutions web à des solutions
d'intelligence en open source qui sont
actuellement déployés par des sociétés
privées ce qui pose la question et bien
de la souveraineté nationale sur sur le
recours à ces outils dont on peut
espérer ou souhaiter qu'elle devrait
être ou justifier d'être développée par
les services de de de l' état doter les
magistrats instructeurs de logiciel tel
que celebrate Pathfinder d'étoffer le
réseau des magistrats de liaison
français à l'étranger notamment en
Amérique du Sud et puis je crois que la
liste de cours est importante mais voilà
les les vœux en tout cas qui sont ceux
qui peuvent être formés par par les GES
pour nous permettre d'être plus efficace
dans la lutte contre ce
narcotrafi alors merci on va déroger à
toutes nos règles parce que
en fait les exposés liumminires auront
consacré constitué l'essentiel de de
l'échange il y a une demande de parole
de de Franck dersin très court et puis
le et puis notre rapporteur
enchaînera évidemment parce que étant
d'unkerercois sénateur du
Nord président du port de calé Boulogne
membre du conseiladministration du port
de dunkererque je baigne un petit peu
dans dans dans dans dans tout cela et et
je retrouve à travers ce que vous
dites un certain nombre de de ENF ça
parle si vous voulez et je je ressens ce
que vous ressentez dans le milieu
portuaire aujourd'hui de très fortes
inquiétudes et de de de fortes pression
sur les personnels parfois même des gens
qui ne cherchent pas du tout à à faire
de choses mauvaises mais qui ont même
des pressions sur les
familles maintenant donc je voulais
intervenir j'ai le retour aussi j'ai pas
mal d'amis policiers à Lille à d'unkerer
ailleurs il y a un vrai problème ils me
le disent mais vous venez de le dire
également sur la police financière de de
de moyens il n'y a pas assez d'hommes
euh euh et on a même retiré des gens et
donc ils ne peuvent pas faire d'enquête
suffisant euh je c'est une question que
je posais je voulais savoir si
effectivement à roubé
euh est-ce que les trafics de droges
peuvent servir euh je dirais à du
terrorisme derrière est-ce que parce
qu'il y a cette cette inquiétude là et
puis bon c'est une affaire mais en
parlais j'ai mais on a parlé des prisons
j'ai été extrêmement choqué de l'article
que j'ai lu hier dans la voie du Nord
sur ce qui se passe à la à la prison de
l'Î annelin où où les le le les les les
les le personnel pénitentier se plaint
depuis des semaines auprès du directeur
qu'un type communique comme il veut fait
ce qu'il veut sur TikTok et que le le le
directeur de la prison refuse de faire
des fouilles et je on sait que en prison
certains continuent à faire les trafics
de drogu voilà je vais pas aller plus
loin j' plein d'autres questions mais
nous en occupons je peux vous assurer
que nous nous en occupons merci Madame
merci Laurent burgois veut enchaîner
juste merci monsieur le Président moi
peut-être un petit zoom surnim puisque
étant un sénateur de gare et remercier
Madame la procureure et son substittu
d'être là dire que on critique souvent
les magistrats mais la modestime Mad le
procureur ne VO pas a dit que dans
l'affaire depuis 20 quand même ça a été
22 personnes qui ont été appréhendé
après un travail d'enquête sur S votre
autorité avec une politique très forte
puisque il y a eu certaines personnes
qui au départ étaient sous contrôle
judiciaire vous avez fait appel la cour
d'appel vous a donné raison donc il y a
beaucoup plus de détention présent il
faut le dire aussi je permet de le dire
par rapport à à à mes collègues sur
travail il a un travail réel de
partenariat également avec le préfet du
gare la chance d'avoir un préfet du Gard
qui est ancien directeur national police
judiciaire donc c'est quelque chose qui
l'intéresse particulièrement mais je
veux dire c'està dire que nous avons un
parquet très actif et moi la seule
question que j'is poser Madame le
Procureur vous l'avez un peu exposé
depuis le 1er jvier dernier on a un GIR
dans le Gard à l'initiative de Monsieur
le Ministre de l'Intérieur comment
envisagez-vous rapidement des liens
entre le parqu le GIR alors c'est c'est
évidemment quelque chose qui va se
discuter y compris avec le procureur
général puisque vous savez que les GIR
est en régionaux pour interlocuteur
direct Monsieur le Procureur général
mais avec lequel je suis en lien euh
l'idée c'est d'en faire véritablement
mais très exactement ce que disait no
collègue une instance de détection des
avoirs pas de saisie de détection
c'est-à-dire dans l'idée que j'en ai
mais encore faut-il que nous en
échangions tous ensemble et je le livre
en primeur ici c'est qu'à chaque enquête
qui nous ramènera sur les stupéfiants
dans ces quartiers notamment mais pas
que il faudra que soit systématiquement
adjointte l'action du GIR pour faire un
environnement patrimonial mais c'est euh
c'est quelque chose que je mets aussi en
lien avec le Codaf ce comité
opérationnel de lutte contre les fraudes
qui nous permet via j'allais dire par
exemple un simple signalement de CPAM de
s'interroger à tout un mode
d'organisation et de financement d'une
famille c'est aussi quelque chose qui
doit être travaillé lorsque par exemple
des personnes ont presque le temps
d'organiser leur détention quand elles
ne sont pas partis assez rapidement pu
qu'elles y partent un peu plus tard et
que on doit s'intéresser à la façon dont
elles sont alimentées en argent pour
pouvoir cantiner et refaire leur leur
vie à l'intérieur de la prison parce que
effectivement il faut s'intéresser aux
prisons de là partent tous les réseaux
qui se maintiennent en réalité et donc
le GIR a vocation à travailler
précisément sur toutes toutes toutes les
situations qui doivent permettre ces
identifications de
patrimoine très bien merci on est
parfaitement désolé parce qu'on avait
sans doute tous une vingtaine ou une
trentaine de questions à vous poser
notamment
euh il y a eu un volet proposition très
important qui nous a particulièrement
intéressé et on aurait aimé l'aborder
vous avez pas eu le temps de le faire
donc moi ce que je propose je vais
travailler ça avec le président avec nos
services il faudra que nous nous
recontactions est-ce que ça sera pour un
échange écrit est-ce que ça sera
éventuellement pour une un échange
direct entre le président vous-même le
rapporteur et vous-même mais j'imagine
que vous êtes un peu frustré je voulais
vous lire simplement nous aussi et je
voudrais vous remercier de la
densité de vos interventions vous avez
pratiquement écrit notre rapport sous
certains aspects quoi voilà mais ça a
été vraiment passionnant moi je vais
vous en remercier et puis on vous
reconactera parce que sur toute une
série de sujets on aura besoin de
précision VO c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'on
avait fait cours pour pouvoir donner
lieu aux échanges on reste à disposition
le casch en visonférence sans aucune
difficulté il y a certainement des
points qui méritent d'être approfondis
et on est très désireux d'accéder à vos
écrits si c'est possible parce que ce
sont les supports qui sont notamment sur
la volet propositionnel qui nous vous
aviez le
notre
merci beaucoup excusez-nous de vous
avoir contraint et on aurait aimé vous
pressurer davantage encore parce qu'il y
avait tant de matière merci merci
Madame